here's the first story from the Daily
Mail Army Sergeant is convicted of
murdering black lives matter protester
by shooting him dead during July 2020
riots in Wake of George Floyd murder
Daniel Perry 37 a 37 year old Uber
driver an army Sergeant was driving
through downtown Austin on the night of
July 25th 2020. he ended up in the
middle of a BLM March and in an
altercation with protester Garrett
Foster uh full stop that's not what
happened Daily Mail is wrong Foster just
walked up to his car with a rifle
pointed it at him and then this guy
fired back that's that's it he didn't
like yell at him or anything nobody was
yelling Perry shot Foster dead claimed
it was self-defense but on Friday jury
found him guilty of murdering as a few
key details which need to be mentioned
first I will say there is a widespread
push from tons of conservative
personalities calling on Greg Abbott to
Pardon this man and I agree not like
this guy look this guy certainly said
some things that I find questionable in
in the past but that is no bearing on
the fact that he's an Uber driver he's
wearing shorts and a t-shirt and
flip-flops and a guy wearing a vast with
a rifle and a mask marching with BLM
points a gun at him and then he fires in
self-defense if they were going to say
you know reckless endangerment or
something I'd roll my eyes and be like
well you know they're getting them
whatever but murder and life in prison
that's what they're going for
they say he was driving through found
himself in the midst of a protest blah
blah blah blah blah let me scroll down
defense lawyers said that Foster raised
his AK-47 at Perry and that Perry fired
in self-defense Witnesses have said
during the trial that Foster never
raised his rifle at Perry well of course
the Witnesses are BLM protesters of
course they are likely to lie
a jury found him guilty in their closing
arguments they insisted he had no choice
but to shoot Foster five times as he
approached Perry's car with an AK-47
prosecutors said Perry had plenty of
choices including driving away full stop
how many stories have we heard where
people who drove away were accused of
hit and run or something because people
are banging on their car so did he and
they opened fire on him I don't care if
you were rioting and you're carrying
weapons and you approach someone and
they and and they're and they they panic
because you're pointing weapon and I'm
sorry and of course I just don't believe
the the BLM people however
they say Perry also said that in Texas
you could get away with shooting them
they mentioned his social media posts
that's probably what got him you should
not say that stuff Perry's phone showed
he was texting woman shortly before the
encounter with Foster the woman he
wanted to meet up with send him a text
asking for money this is an age-old
story about a man who couldn't keep his
anger under control he said about police
it's not about protest Marchers it is
there's video I'm I'm not going to play
the video but look people have a right
to keep in bear arms people have a right
to March down the street with those
weapons you don't have a right to be
part of a group that is that has
committed several acts of terrorism over
the past over the previous days and then
surround someone's vehicle while
pointing a rifle at them that's just
that you've crossed the line and so my
response to all this is it's a horrible
story I wish it didn't happen it sucks
but how is putting this guy in prison
going to solve anything
uh it's a sensitive it's a sensitive
story and I don't have a lot of data on
this I really what it comes down to is
this guy pointing the gun at him or not
and we only have witness testimony
because if he has the gun and it's like
at an angle right past pointing right
past the guy and he's moving towards the
guy it could give the illusion that he's
gonna that he's pointing towards him but
and and I don't know where where how far
away were the witnesses
how do you get him on murder
because because of the idea that he
premeditated it or had intent with that
post on social media and so and so the
let me read this protesters didn't know
anything about Perry when they attacked
the car and boxed it in said Doug
O'Connell who was defend defending Perry
O'Connell argued that Foster was dressed
for battle at the protest including
wearing a neoprene vest carrying an
AK-47 a club and a knife Perry was
wearing a t-shirt shorts and flip-flops
Garrett Foster is dressed for war Daniel
Perry is dressed for the beach
murder means intent if they want to say
reckless endangerment or negligent
homicide I'd be sitting here we'd be
arguing the legal merits no they they
convicted him for intentionally going to
this guy and killing him
I thought and I think because as you're
bringing up with the social media post
and they were trying to say see aha he
wanted this chance to do what he did I
think what it actually shows is his
mindset is like oh my gosh look how
scary these you know these rioters are
these looters are you know the different
social media posts that he had so when
he turns the corner and I think during
the trial it came out that there was
evidence that his car was slowing
because all the witnesses to your point
earlier about the witnesses saying well
he didn't point the gun well the
witnesses also said that he sped up into
them and I think they said oh we just
heard tires screeching and this and that
but then I think the evidence of the
trial show that his car was decelerating
correct decelerated to less quadriplegic
woman exactly use the crosswalk so there
are lines into it yeah so he turns into
and he's like oh my gosh and his mindset
is I've been following this for months
now how scary I don't want to be the
next guy to die oh my gosh a gun's in my
face now I think that more accurately
describes why he has those past social
media posts rather rather than what the
you know prosecutors are trying to say
is that oh he's a bad man looking for a
fight and other Witnesses have testified
that they had called the cops saying
this group is carrying guns we've asked
them to leave we can't do anything I
mean all the outlets are describing as
like they were marching everything's
fine but like put yourself back into
this summer of 2020. it was an extremely
turbulent and violent times in major
cities Across America and people who
were sort of caught in the crosshairs
residents who lived in the area just had
to wait and hope that nothing that fatal
would happen and fortunately in this
case it did and I wonder if his defense
was smart enough to bring up this story
from Deseret police arrest two after man
shot during Provo protest that's right
BLM ran up to a truck for no reason
literally none this guy wasn't this
wasn't a truck driver chasing anybody
down it was a guy driving on the street
BLM extremists ran up and shot the guy
in his car June 30th 2020. and they say
two people who are arrested Tuesday
night in connection with the shooting of
a motorist about one month later
this army Sergeant was driving down the
street in Austin when he was approached
by a guy with a gun and shot back and
that context I think is extremely
important for the jury to understand the
this faction of individuals their
ideology they have been committing acts
of Terror they have been killing people
and only a couple weeks ago walked up to
a motorist and shot him and here I'm in
my car is what I'd say and they were
walking up to me and I said here we go
again that's the gun he points it at me
but you know what it doesn't matter
because they're in Austin
and I I think anybody I I find it
laughable that people are like you go to
move to Austin man and I was like no no
you don't you do not want to live in
these places you will go to prison when
they try to kill you and you try to
defend yourself yeah and it seems so
obvious that it was self-defense in this
particular instance but what I would
like to know is there's been other
pretty egregious police killings of
litany of minorities as well as white
people since the Biden Administration
came to power you have not heard from
black lives matter in terms of protests
and riots and things like that and and
what that tells me is that it was it was
catalyzed somehow and we still don't
have answers as to how that came to pass
and I would like to know
you mean the Riots of 2020 yeah the
whole summer man it was crazy it was
like three it was basically 100 days of
just misery and insanity and and I just
don't buy the organic nature of that and
for the life of me I wish oan or some
you know some organization that's
actually interested in getting to the
truth would would dig into that because
it seems like there's a story there and
I don't know what it is right what are
you gonna say oh uh go ahead oh you're
gonna be much more interesting than me I
was just going to say on one point yes
it kind of reads like you know color
revolutions and stuff where these big
muddied interests that they go out there
and they're able to kind of fund and
they can kind of put money into it they
can kind of get people amped up and out
there on the streets I think Foster was
on the streets I think
yeah exactly so he kind of was like a
full-time protester Rider at that point
one thing that I do think is interesting
to perhaps bring up here is that I know
he was I know I think reporting says he
was a Boogaloo boy right the the
fostering so I know the big gun control
culture right however he was rolling
with BLM and of course we saw a lot of
that kind of you know mix in the summer
of 2020 with the riots but it's
interesting to me because with BLM and
other left-wing groups one of their
Hallmarks is pushing for gun control
yeah it's interesting that it's only
specific groups it's only like law
abiding regular Americans that they want
gun control for you see the Chas for
example antifa and other Related Group
Johns Brown's clubs the rest it's
interesting that when they set up their
little chats what did they first do they
erected a border they patrolled that
border with armed guards and they
deported anyone they didn't like from
the area and you've seen that over and
over and over with these groups so when
they say gun control they don't really
mean gun control they just want to be
the ones with the guns and the people
they don't like not having the guns in
this case Foster and friends having guns
and the Perry and his friends not having
guns boom and then we saw in Wisconsin
when BLM protesters cheered and clapped
as a man was arrested in his own home
I thought they were supposed to be
against the cops no no when the police
come and arrest you they are clapping
for it that's where we're going that's
where we are
yeah disturbing so what are the odds you
think that uh Abbott steps up and does
something about this I think it's
actually pretty high you know because
I'm I I look
this is violent extremists they've
killed other people before there's 20
plus deaths there's there's 19 plus
deaths directly tied to the protest and
an estimated 32 in the periphery of of
the riots I shouldn't say protest riots
this guy in his shorts and t-shirt
convicted of murder something's wrong
here uh Abbott needs to just pardon yeah
well let me let me say one quick thing
in defense of the Boogaloo boys which
will be very unpopular but uh many of
them are Libertarians and many of them
are hard 2A guys and many of them were
out there just to defend the protesters
from the police however if you're going
to approach someone and you're
protesting in the middle of the street
and you have a vehicle that is now
stopped and surrounded and you approach
them with an AK-47 or whatever sort of
assault right well I don't even want to
say assault rifle the the scary looking
guns
um not a good idea it's not just that
the Boogaloo boys have uh uh been
praised for for they're not they're not
directly anti for BLM no they're not but
if you are Marching with antifa and BLM
There's no distinction sorry these
people have firebombed buildings they
have killed people uh Michael reinel in
Portland with a BLM communist tattoo on
his neck shot Aaron Danielson twice in
the chest and then you're like you know
what I'm gonna march with these people
it's like well with a with a rifle and
you pointed at someone and people are
pointing on the chat there's a video of
him holding the weapon at high ready
he's got the gun ready to go if a guy
approaches you high ready with a rifle
at high ready man in the middle of a a
riot and you're stuck and you can't move
you've got to assume the worst what
choice I'm not trying to incite stuff
but like what what are you supposed to
do in that situation you have to protect
yourself yeah you can either just put
your hands down and stick your chest out
right out of the tip of his gun maybe
but like what's the other choice here no
consider the game consider the options
exactly you have to hit the guess drive
through in which case you're going to
get an attempted homicide charge or you
fire in which case you're charged with
murder and apparently convicted or you
just cross your fingers and hope that
the dude's not gonna fire him this is
beyond just happening to somebody in a
vehicle with BLM we saw the the the the
the
um parking garage attendant in New York
right who a guy literally shot him twice
fighting for his life this man wrestles
The Gun away and then shoots the
would-be murderer and then he wakes up
being criminally charged with attempted
murder in a hospital after nearly dying
and he's crying he was crying in bed
saying I don't understand this is a
nightmare what's happening why are they
doing this to me because they're evil
people they are evil there's no question
I'm sorry Ian it is a fact if a man is
on his death bed after being shot twice
and he's crying saying why why why God
it's because Bragg is an evil person and
the only reason he backed up that
prosecution is because people who are
good stood up and said don't you try it
and then he backed up and said no okay
okay we're gonna stop do you think you
too Muslim is evil in general well it's
the to a certain degree but let me make
this point what's happening to this guy
Daniel Perry
I was surprised to find out the trial
was going on how did we not know about
this how is this story which is similar
to Kyle Rittenhouse different in many
ways completely just under arms there's
no video no video there is video is it
good video is it enough to know what's
going on no I mean from what I've read
everyone is saying it's not super clear
even the police body cam footage
responding to the incident is like a
little ambiguous I mean the defense
called uh their own ballistics expert to
try and analyze the video and I think
that's one of the reasons that uh Kyle
Rittenhouse was able to not get lost in
sort of the immediate uh media backlash
that would have inevitably followed him
because so many who could point to this
video and say look at it like you can't
spin this it's pretty obvious what
happened here yeah look at this story
from Deseret
how are we supposed to live in a country
where you hear the news about BLM for no
reason shooting a motorist so I believe
I believe it was a woman you can see it
and people are mentioning in the chat
and then
what do you do you know what look man
you want to live in Austin fine at a
certain point I've got I'm I'm getting
to the point where I'm going to be like
oh did another person get convicted of
murder for for trying to save their
their own life no sympathy yeah I'm
sorry I'm sorry dudes look
I'm not going to say it's not I'm not
going to say it's easy for a lot of
people to get out of cities very very
hard very very difficult but
Amish at the point where I'm like I mean
how many it's three years on three years
since the summer of love and I've been
saying even two years before that you
need to get out of these cities they
will do this to you they will arrest you
for what BLM does yeah if there's a
Democrat D.A you're in trouble and there
are people who are still like yeah I'll
be fine I'll keep my head down it's like
okay when that happens and they do come
and arrest you don't expect me to to
offer any assistance do you think one of
the biggest things is because those who
are on
I guess right libertarian various
assorted groups is that we kind of don't
like you know state power so much so
it's more like elections come by we're
not as into it as say someone who is one
of the left ideological you know groups
so when local elections come around
we're not as mobilized and we're not as
interested like you said with this uh
this this trial a lot of people weren't
as you know paying attention to it as
much so I think that happens a lot
because even if you get out of cities
you could be in a smaller town where you
know everyone seems to be kind of maybe
more conservative and you think wow I
feel really safe here everyone supports
law enforcement and then before you know
it you didn't pay attention to your
local elections and Eric how come this
da is letting everyone out how come my
you know and on and on but the the issue
is it's not bad enough and so there is
one simple reality if you are holding on
to a skillet and it burns your hand you
will let go
the issue is the damage and destruction
that is occurring in cities is not is
not escalating to a point just yet where
people are going to drop the pan I.E get
out now let me give you analogy right
you grab a you put on your oven mitts
and you grab a a tray of fudge brownies
from the oven
and you're holding on to it and you're
trying to figure out where to put the
brownies down and you can feel the heat
is making its way through those mitts
what happens if you don't put it down
right now
eventually the mitts can't stop the heat
it burns your hand you drop the pan
maybe it's Pyrex it shadows in the
ground and now there's a disaster Zone
when instead you could have been like
okay I gotta just set this down anywhere
I can set it down it's getting too hot
what's happening right now is we're at
that point people are still in these
cities and we can feel the heat but
they're going look the heat that I'm
feeling the pressure that I'm feeling in
the city does not reach a level where
I'm willing to experience hardship to
get out and I mean it hardship I'm not
saying it's easy it might be the most
difficult thing you've ever done but
trust me the people who have said to me
like you look man I got a house I can't
sell it I don't know how to move trust
me when bullets fly through your
daughter's window you will pack up and
leave and go sleep under a bridge or
something like that you will be like
okay that is too hot and so my point is
simply this
I'm not passing judgment I'm simply
saying I understand why people are not
going to leave their homes until the
bullets come through their windows but
you know what it's already happened to a
lot of people yep and so like that guy
in Wisconsin
sooner or later the cop will come to
your house they will search your home
they will charge you with whatever they
want because you pissed off some BLM
activist group because they know who you
are you watch this show and then you're
going to be like it's too late now yeah
now the the D.A is going to be like Mr
Smith don't leave the state and you're
going to be like now what do I do I got
to say real quick I'm reading Scott
Horton's pre-release of his new book
it's like 500 pages on the history
between uh Russia and Ukraine it's
incredible but the reason this
correlates and there is a correlation
he breaks down all of the color
revolutions that happened through the
Eastern Bloc Nations that were CIA
backed and I can't tell you how
reminiscent it was of living through
2020. and it just it strikes me as a
color Revolution I'm not saying it was
one but it felt a hell of a lot like one
when you read about them it's crazy it's
uncanny honestly what defines color
Revolution usually they're labeled by a
color so it'll be like the orange or the
rose or the red and things like that so
um but there's a Litany of them that
happen in Eastern Bloc Nations like the
break-off nations from Russia after the
fall of the USSR and
usually it deals with
electoral processes that are manipulated
in some fesh I'm not saying that's what
happened in America but that is what the
uh the CIA was
I want to read this Council from uh
Vision storm he says Tim quote I'm not
passing judgment I'm just saying I have
no sympathies if you have no means to
leave your state no you completely
misunderstand perhaps intentionally
what I said is
for those who poo Pooh the idea and say
ah it's not that bad
that is to whom I'm saying I have no
sympathy if you've made this choice
right I'm also saying I understand for
some people it is too difficult to do
it's very difficult
and then I'm also pointing out that at a
certain point it doesn't matter how
difficult it is or the consequences you
will drop the tray the glass will
shatter and it will create a problem for
you this is what I'm saying if you are
holding something too hot
shattering glass on the ground is the
war is the last thing you want to happen
if you are living in a house and you're
like I have nowhere to put this thing
down the moment BLM shows up to your
house and it's a fire you will flee your
home with your kids having no idea where
you're going it's not a question of your
means to do so it is a fact if your life
your loved ones lives are threatened you
will go and sleep in a tent in the woods
before you let a violent mob kill you I
like that's it like I don't think
there's any human being who's going to
be like oh Auntie fussier what are they
yelling they want to kill me I better
just sit here especially when you have
kids you're going to be like we're
abandoning this right it's got to go so
my view is it may be the most difficult
thing you have ever done
if it were me I don't want to give
anybody Financial advice if it weren't
me I would sell my house for whatever I
could get for it and move to move out to
the middle of nowhere that being said I
am fully aware of when we moved out of
Jersey it wasn't the most difficult
thing for us you know I I had a
successful YouTube channel I had money
that I'd saved up and so after saving
for about a year or two and I'm like I
think we better get out of here before
it's too late so then we bought property
out here in West Virginia got a little
tiny house somewhere and that's it
that's it and then we moved out here set
up the company in this in in what is now
the cast Castle which is the companies
you know I don't live here and that's
the point I understand for me it was it
was much easier and I moved much sooner
than most people but I do think sooner
or later
if you do nothing there will come a time
when BLM will come up to your house
they'll be armed for some reason or
another maybe you'll be at work and and
they're going to be or maybe this could
not get an American flag in the front of
your house they've already done this BLM
has already threatened people because
they had American flags on their houses
sooner or later in these cities it will
it will happen
you want to buy my my point to people is
if you could buy a lottery ticket
and if you won the lottery on it then
they would lock you that put you in
prison for life like that was the prize
the chance of it happening are very very
low but would you buy the ticket anybody
no so the chances of BLM actually
showing up to your house in the
immediate future right now and
destroying it is a lottery ticket's
chance okay over time it's slowly
becoming more and more likely we are
seeing more and more of this several
years on now they're putting people in
prison after BLM attacked them
look at the cash up founder too in in
San Francisco exactly do you think there
was something like that because that was
2 A.M I think he was doing a drug deal
or something no right now he was he was
he was that guy must have been worth a
billion dollars he's walking out drunk
what was it 2 A.M why was he outside at
2 A.M in San Francisco on a weekend yeah
everybody's out at 2 am in a week
drinking maybe he was in San Francisco
was a major urban area where he used to
live I mean he could be coming home he
was going to his house he was going to
his apartment wasn't he yeah he was like
he was at his apartment it wasn't a bad
area and his family what don't don't
take that and I don't know why it's it's
simple Bro 2 A.M in New York yes 2 A.M
bars close at four don't walk around in
cities at 2 A.M guys unless you
absolutely have to stick to the bright
lit streets walk fast like you're the
one that's dangerous and think about 360
as much as you can think about what
you're saying
that's all you got to live in a city man
it's dog eat dog or you get out because
or get out if you can it's insane
beautiful out in the open yeah it is
insane that we've gotten to the point
where it's like if you go out at 2 A.M
in a city you might die yeah that's not
and then here's the best part the person
who did it is gonna get let go
yeah you can't trust that there'll be
any justification I think the video you
have to be conscious of that the water
is boiling right like true you may not
lose everything today but do you want to
be in the place most likely to be the
next epicenter of one of these rights of
course probably not and it is difficult
to leave but make it a priority like
this is something that you maybe need to
make a goal thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time